so i was inspired by those features and
i interviewed them for two years at a
club what do you mean you interviewed
them anybody that would talk to me
formally informally i would ask them
questions like what do i need to know
about the business how do i get on the
box cover how do i get my name
incorporated how do i make the most
money what things do i not want to do
who do i not want to work with so in
that two-year span they gave me mailing
addresses of different people hustler
um
metro calvis all the different companies
that were producing vhs back then and i
started having photos shot and i would
email them right this was before you
could google anything anything they
would give me an address and be like
here write to this woman she's larry
flynn's assistant send her photos and so
i would write and they would write me
back or we would do a long distance
phone call which back then was like a
calling card it was like you know it was
it was a whole hassle um and it took me
two years um and then finally through
one of the girls that i was interviewing
every six months when she came to the
club she introduced me to a guy who
helped the right girls get contracts i
knew by the time i was 20 that i didn't
want to get in the business and just
shoot scenes i wanted to be a contract
girl because you got a salary you got
you know carte blanche at all the events
you got all the best promotional
materials for feature dance gigs posters
merch t-shirts what have you and i knew
that my main goal was really to be on
the road and seeing the world it wasn't
really just to be shooting scenes so by
being a contract girl you only shoot one
movie a month
so you can shoot those all over the
summer and then go out on the road for
the rest of the year if you want to add
this great flexibility i had this whole
concept so wait were there celebrities
back then at this time in in that
industry like names who were the big
names when you were big names when i was
first getting in with savannah
uh diana loren nikki dial recaldarian
janine julia ann
there were a lot of beautiful vivid
girls everybody remembers the vivid
girls um christy canyon who i met at 18
and we're still friends today
um so many of these women that like
remembered me knocking on their dressing
room door and saying hey do you have a
couple minutes tonight for me to ask you
a couple more questions i had this like
ongoing notebook
[Music]
you